vous aviez dit sur bfm tv vous avez fait
une déclaration vous êtes revenu dessus
ensuite est-ce que vous avez regretté ce
que vous regrettez aujourd'hui mode et
la déclaration qu'il avait faite sur bfm
ou pas de nom n'est d'ailleurs je n'ai
pas regretté de l'avoir dit peut-être
d'une manière qui n'a pas été comprise
mais en même temps je pense que
n'importe quel médecin sexothérapeute
aurait dit ça ça n'aurait pas fait ce
scandale la wii c'est parce que c'était
moi avec mon passé etc
et je ne regrette pas parce que ça a
ouvert le débat est ce que je dis dans
le livre est ce que je pense et ce que
je sais c'est que les femmes qui ont eu
cet orgasme mécaniques sont des femmes
qui ont eu encore plus de mal à se
reconstruire double paraît et le fait
exactement double peine et donc je crois
qu'il ya des moments où il faut si on
veut vraiment parler de ce que c'est que
l'abus sexuel et le viol va il faut dire
les choses clairement ça a toujours été
ma manière de parler de sexualité c'est
pas tout blanc ou tout noir c'est
complexe et je crois que s'il ya
quelqu'un qui sait parler de sexualité
c'est moi c'est sûr que c'est pas
journée affirmé jose alors je vous étiez
vous parliez vous voulez des intrus vous
parler de la sortie du livre de woods
vous dites pourquoi l'avoir sorti
maintenant parce que c'est vrai que
c'est juste après c'était prévu mais
voilà cela du tout non non ce n'est pas
absolument pas prévu c'est albin michel
qui est venu me demander de le faire je
réfléchis de trois jours je me suis dit
bon de toute façon au point où j'en suis
un peu plus beaucoup ils les vivent
comme une sorcière ou pas qu'il ya des
gens qui vous et puis il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont d'accord avec moi et
et en général les gens que j'ai croisés
depuis mois de janvier me disent de
continuer et mes auditeurs continua je
suis prêt je peux comprendre que ça
dérange je pense que c'est plus presque
un problème de deux femmes qui ont envie
de
d'où certaines choses et d'autres femmes
qui comme moi ont envie êtres d'être des
femmes libres voilà moi j'ai pas envie
que ce soit l'homme qui décide si c'est
si j'ai envie si j'ai bu si j'ai pas bu
non je voudrais tu es libre